hey everybody Welcome to an indulgent
wild ride with steo we're really really
indulging ourselves over here man we're
talking about busting nuts and eating
chicken being the most Sublime
experience of all time and then there's
old Scott Randolph I mean dude what
isn't he doing to indulge himself I mean
I'm telling you this guy's hilarious
stavos man I've really really hit it off
with him and he's my new bro so get
ready for a hilarious indulgent Wild
Ride let's get to it ladies and
gentlemen stavos hus hell yeah thanks
for having me dog yeah dude I said that
right you nailed it you nailed it great
yeah yeah yeah man thanks for doing it
dude I've a seen you I've seen you
everywhere you're on fire thank you I'm
trying to be shout out to the algorithm
I don't know what happened but it it
Lifted Me it lifted me into the you know
I I caught in that [__] and I
just got to get famous off posting uh
Tik toks somehow oh W that was it huh I
mean I had some [__] going before I was
uh had a big podcast before come I was
on come toown that really helped a lot
but then something just happened where I
was like I'll just I was putting out my
special and I was like let me just see
what happens if I put out some dumb
little clips and you know here we are
wow I feel like I feel like that's been
happening a lot with
comedians they just blowing up over Tik
Tok yeah like comedians that have been
working for years to over 10 years and
then all of a sudden they get this crazy
viral clip and then now they're selling
out shows is that like a Matt R thing is
that how he kind of started blow up yeah
I think it's the same thing it's
literally the same thing except you know
like people talk about how it's easy to
be fat and like look funny in comedy but
like if you just are ripped and have
dsls you're going to do better you know
what I mean like Matt R is just a piece
of ass like the algorithm still
understands like [__] people more
than anything you know what I mean
because all it is like quick looking
like that's why someone with big ass
titties is going to go go further you
know what I mean like someone with as
long as you just kind of because I know
that's what my algorithm is all it's
either like you know delicious meals or
big ass someone with big tits or like a
it started with Fitness like cuz I was
like trying to work out and then slow
like one hot girl would sneak in but she
was still doing like you know showing
you how to do an exercise then slowly
you know there was less about the
exercise you could see more of her [__]
through her shorts that's a big thing
with Fitness with like Fitness like uh
TI Tok accountants it's like yeah yeah
yeah but it's like ostensibly uh it's
ostensibly for Fitness but it's like you
are just I don't know who designs the
shorts that had they it feels like they
have specific like [__] material to
make it even more visible than any other
short I've done a lot of time I've spent
a lot of time on that part of Tik Tok
for sure [__] talk
yeah so it wasn't um the special itself
the special definitely helped right like
that was the whole idea was like I was
trying to get uh I was just trying to
post [__] so that people would see the
special because my YouTube channel
didn't have [__] really going on I had
like 20,000 followers but then the clips
got it to like you know I don't know 300
400,000 and then the special itself then
got it like up another
you know but yeah the special did really
well I was just trying to so it it's
kind of like a onetwo punch where it's
like you have the clips and then you're
like hey I also can do not crowd work
here's like an hour of jokes um and uh
and then plus you know if you're on the
road and just doing a good show people
will come back and see you more and more
so for sure man uh so I was struck
watching your uh live at the lodge
special your cander about uh taking drug
drugs yeah yeah yeah definitely I mean
like it's pretty wild like you know I
think most people if they do partake in
cocaine they're not going to say that
very loudly at a public level sure yeah
yeah well that's the whole point of
standup is that like it's a it's I mean
it's a [__] art form and all we
could it's like you're just supposed to
have a good time the two things that I
think are very important with standup is
like have a good ass time let people
like laugh that's it right just
entertain people but also if there's one
thing we can kind of that has artistic
Merit I think is just being completely
open and honest and I think that's the
best standup you can do be a really good
standup and just write jokes that aren't
don't really tell people about you but I
think what I'm interested in when I
think we kind of get to Artistic Merit
is when like yeah dude you're just an
open book and that's what's interesting
about it it's just a person legitimately
and that's why I like talking to the
audience and I'll be very you know open
with them and I talk it's not just drugs
it's you know talk about my family I
talk about you know all my sexual
embarrassments you know of which there
are many you know what I mean and so
yeah I mean yeah I was definitely I was
definitely in the zone I mean I don't I
don't do cocaine anymore because my rule
is after 30 it's either be fat or do
cocaine I don't think you could do both
you know what I mean that's a little
tough on the
ticker really you're you're really
risking it over there but yeah you know
I'll still do a mushroom every once in a
while I'll still do a little acid
obviously some weed I watched you know
got high watched Lone Wolf McQuade two
days ago really great picture I suggest
you check it out but yeah man I love uh
that's the whole point is just like
being honest and let people in on your
[__] was it difficult to stop doing
cocaine not really I'm much more of a
downer guy I like just like I am happy I
didn't grow up in like the age of opium
dens cuz that would have been my [__]
you know what I mean just like laying on
a little mattress you know what I mean
smoking op yeah exactly getting sucked
off by like a big titted uh someone who
had been like a prostitute that came
over on like a ship you know what I mean
like that would have been that would
have been my life in the 1800s yeah no
question the the nicker Bacher Clive
Owen frequented those places yeah hell
yeah I do they still they got they got
opium dens they did in like the 1902 oh
yeah dude that's yeah thank God there's
no time machines either cuz still the
cleanliness might be a problem if I went
back in time but if I was of the era I'd
be in there yeah I'd like you know I'd
like the little pills that kind of stuff
but you know it never got that out of
control because my biggest addiction for
sure is food it's not even close so it's
like you know and that's why my favorite
drug the one I have the most problems
with is actually weed where it's like
it's this it's like the it's the most
gentle one but it's like that's the one
that [__] my life up the most because I
just wow you know it starts with like
let me just smoke a little to go to bed
and then it's like you know then you're
like oh I have I have 38 minutes before
this incredible incredibly important
meeting I could take a 40 milligram
edible you know what I mean like it
becomes that I'll sleep it off in you
know a half hour and be ready to go but
you know it also enhances being fat as
[__] too because you get to right
there's nothing like just getting high
and ordering you know $40 of Chinese
food and you got you got your favorite
Ben and& Jerry's just locked and loaded
in the fre in the freezer you know what
I mean I
um have had times when I felt hard done
by that I can't smoke weed anymore yeah
that's why I I don't like to like go to
concerts and stuff like when whenever I
smell weed it's kind of upsetting to me
because I love the way it smells and and
and if I'm honest like I I would love to
be able to smoke weed yeah the problem
is that my weed bone is connected to my
booze bone my booze bone connected
toone my Coke bone is connected to my
pill
bone yeah and next thing you know it's
it's all PCP and uh you know so I'm I'm
very clear that I can't and sometimes
that just that that that hurts my
feelings oh I get that dude so uh
Baltimore yeah dude that uh that's a
tough
Town yeah I mean it was but it's like
you don't know any better when you grow
up there and also like I grew up in
Greek toown which was you know we had
like one murder a year you know what I
mean and it was like big it was big news
but it wasn't like you never really felt
like you were in danger you know what I
mean it's like and I was very lucky I
never got I never got robbed or anything
like I had a lot of friends who were
like uh
because like in every in every like City
where you know in every like City that's
not doing well finan like economically I
feel like the Arts Center is also right
by a horrific neighborhood so I had a
lot of like artsy like [__] you know
scrawny friends who were just like like
I had one of my friends like this little
ass dude who's so I mean he's he's very
creative he's awesome but like he would
get robbed just constantly like he would
just Factor it into his like budgeting
that like I'm going to get robbed you
know what I mean but I think you know
what what does getting robbed look like
in in Baltimore you know just somebody
stopping you maybe having a gun maybe
pretending to have a gun have you know
and just being like just running your
pockets or just not you know knocking
you out a lot of my friends would get
like sucker punched and [__] like that
but if you just like looked in if you
just did looked harder to ro I think
being fat I was just like if you had to
pick a guy that if you had to Pi fat and
still like uh you know ambulatory like
not not like shuffling sideways but like
if you could if you were fat and could
move in a straight line pretty nice if
if you hadn't hit the like you know the
threshold of like way too fat and and
easy to like topple over I think you're
was like I'd rather rob a smaller man so
you are an intimidating fat I think I
was just I just you know just crossed
the line of just enough where if you
didn't know me may you know what I mean
maybe it's like why don't we let's not
it's like it's just safer to Rob someone
who's uh you know not as fat you know
what I mean like just goey just you
never know with a fat guy might be a
powerlifter I was not but you know what
I mean there are some sneaky powerful
fat men out there let pent up Rage with
fat people that's another thing you
could tap into that in my 20s I could
tap into yeah not getting [__] like
just just incel fat rage there's nothing
anybody can do to stop you no no if it
gets gets released usually you turn it
inside and you eat you know crumpets to
to to make it go away you know what I
mean I I only fairly recently learned
the definition of incel yeah yeah yeah
is that crazy like is there not more
than one definition of incel I think
it's it's like a military term no no
what it means is uh somebody who is
involuntarily celibate yeah oh that's
what incel means inel no it was like a
military TR like we got like three
incels over here in the
building let that sink in what the [__]
is going on you guys you're all you you
guys have a huge internet presence you
don't know incels I guarantee you a lot
of incels subscribed to the channel I'll
tell you that much I me I know how to
spell it it's probably i n c l right
there you go that doesn't count if
that's not anything it's like sop it's a
sophisticated word for a guy who wants
[__] you can't get it well let me tell
you about something anybody can get
sto's hot sauce for your butthole sto's
butthole Destroyer hot sauce anybody can
get these great stocking stuffers on
Amazon and there's my bobble head which
anybody can get at sto.com but the
important question is how do I ship
these awesome things to the people who
order them I use ship station why
because it brings everything you need to
run an Ecommerce business into one place
all of the different shipping Services
FedEx UPS United States Postal Service
and can see the best rates like that are
normally reserved for Fortune 500
companies and man I'm telling you we
just have our warehouse when the order
comes in print the label slap it on the
box stick the goods in there it's out
the door it's so easy and the holidays
are coming up and I wish you were
excited as I am because we're going to
do a great deal of business and you
should too plus if you want to get a
absolutely risk-free two months free
trial then go to
shipstation.com and to use the promo
code steo that's 60 days two months and
you get to try this service see how easy
it is how good the rates are and how
much you can blow up your business so
one more time for that easy free
risk-free 60-day trial go to
shipstation.com and use the promo code
steo Listen People the holidays are upon
us and it's time to make ship happen now
let's get back to it get
push involuntarily yeah invol he wants
to be crushing beef but oh so I was an
incel for a very long time without
question without question involuntary
cell but I read that you're married
that's not true I'm not where didd you
read that I think on Wikipedia that's
not on my Wikipedia I think it said it
said that you were married one one it
said you were married to a dude and then
another article I I I read said that you
were married to a girl okay well no and
I even said that to you I was like oh I
didn't know you was gay and then yeah we
got a crack research department on the
Wild Ride
pod yeah I saw it somewhere you were gay
or married or something what was that
like oh on kyani
news.ng yeah what is that it Shar that
The spouse's name of stabos is Adam
freem That's My Boy Adam we used to do
come toown together so it's a joke of
you know it'd be like saying steo is
married to wean and somebody believing
that okay you know what I'm saying but
that's all right guilty that's okay uh
the uh the the disbanding of the come
toown
podcast it uh is is that shrouded and
and Scandal and controversy it's not I
mean I think it's a little bit people
are curious but I think like you know
kind of what it was just time to move on
for me personally where it was like I
was pretty burned out and I thought not
doing the Pod was what I wanted to kind
of like chill out um and then because of
like I plan to just kind of like take it
really easy after stopping the podcast
and then all that like I said all that
random the internet [__] kind of blew up
without me expecting to so I left the
Pod thinking I'd be like way less busy
and just kind of be able to focus on
myself and like you know because we joke
about you know obviously you understand
somebody having their demons like I
really felt like kind of the stress of
being on the road constantly and like
trying you know I hadn't had the special
yet and I was like I really wanted to
break through as a standup and not as a
podcast guy that always kind of bothered
me a little bit so I just wanted to kind
of focus on standup and then maybe get
healthier and do that [__] and so I
figured let's stop and then let me stop
and and chill out and then [__] blew up
and I was like [__] I'm making a lot of
money on the road now I can't stop so
now it's like not only did I the podcast
ended and then I just was like well I'm
getting all these new fans I should have
a podcast so I started another podcast
like six months later just because it
was like the right business decision um
but I think it ended up for the best
where and and like other than me getting
fatter and fatter the last few years and
getting more and more [__] up
everything else has been going great you
know everything else like ended up for
the best and um I think the show was
probably going to end that year anyway
so it was just we pulled the I puled you
know I kind of left a little earlier
just for my own [__] and then um you
just said look Cooks I'm done with you
yeah I just can't do this [__] I just I
need a little time to myself and then I
took like two weeks to myself and then I
was like [__] this shit's kind of blown
up that when you said uh that you were
working on getting healthier yeah I I
found myself like kind of starting to
giggle because I pictured you watching
Tik toks to get healthy yeah and and and
it just turned into jacking my dick
getting hard I can't tell you how often
that has happened where it's like I'll
be like I'll be looking through like my
saved recipes where it's like healthy
like egg white [__] and then I just flip
to the next one and it's like you know
someone teaching you deadlift form and
then within four it's just a fat titted
Russian lady just bench pressing in the
and she's like was mushing her tits and
I'm like I'm going to search yoga pants
in x videos and see what I get after
that yeah that's that that's fantastic
man um do you have any like uh things on
the road that you do to like meal prep
or I mean I try I mean when the when it
starts like when the when the when the
tours would start I definitely was like
uh you know I I would like order meals
and I one time I flew my brother has a
gym shout out to Nick uh uh Odyssey
strength and conditioning folks if
you're out in Maryland and so he would
train me he came out to Houston when I
was there and I but then it just like it
just gets so [__] hectic I don't know
how you guys feel about the road but
it's like it's I can start I can start
okay and then it's just like the and I
was on you know I've been on the road
basically with a couple breaks here and
there since the pandemic ended like as
soon as you could stay get on the road
and it's this weird thing where it's
like you know I grew up poor [__] and so
it's like and I was making some money
off come I was making good money on come
toown and then I I was doing well ticket
sell wise right like I was doing well
you know comedy clubs selling out one or
two shows but then once this [__]
internet [__] popped it was it was like
I was making the kind of money on the
road where I was like this probably and
you know I don't know if you feel this
way like I'm pessimistic where I'm like
this is not going to last right so it's
this thing of like something someone's
going to realize no one should be paying
theater price is for com standup comedy
somebody's going to re like there's
going to be a mass people are going to
figure this out we're going to be you
know we're going to be exposed as the
frauds we are and sent back to comedy
clubs to make like half the money and so
I just like kept saying yes to more and
more stuff to the point where you know
now I've saved up a good amount of money
um but it would be like every tour would
start like oh I'm not going to go too
crazy and then I would just add more and
more stuff and then buy you know and
then I'm like I'm going to the first
weekend you're like eating salads and
[__] and then like you know 4 months in
it's just like I can't sleep so I'm get
taking Edibles I'm taking I've gotten
fat as hell so I'm taking dick pills
just to make my dick even sort of work
you know what I'm like so and you're
just like in s I'm just in such disarray
where I'm just like you know overheating
all the time I'm in like you know I'm
taking like cold baths to get going so
so when you're taking the dick pills
make the dick sort of work yes I'd love
to get into this for
sure I have a lot of thoughts on so
let's get in there I mean of course
we're talking about blue Cho are you are
they are they a sponsor of the and I
happen to love them okay well look I
have some beef with the general dick
pill uh Market because I'm out there as
a free agent and I you know what I mean
I don't have no ads on stav's world when
it comes to dick pills and I'm just
saying everyone's [__] up because I'm
a I am on the record years a proud user
of the product with with I mean it's in
my spe I've talked about it in specials
so you know I'm I can't say steo exactly
which I'm talking about until they cut a
check I can't say who what dick pills
are making my dick get to 65% hard so I
can mash it so I can mash it into some
woman who probably had a fat carismatic
father and that's the reason she's
agreed to suck me off in my hotel room
and then leave immediately afterwards
you know what I mean that's you know I
can't I can't specify the brand but if
you want to say it's blueo that's fine
with me I won't I won't [__] your money
up yeah that that thought process I mean
is that what you're thinking about when
the chick's sucking your dick it's like
I probably look like your
father yeah yeah yeah no no in the
moment I'm thinking
nice this is [__] awesome in the
moment and then I bust and that's when
those thoughts come in you know and then
then you eat [__] M&M's or something
in the corner room oh dude it's really
[__] up what like truly nothing makes
me happier than just getting a nice
little nut off and then hanging out with
someone with fat titties and eating like
chicken tenders and a hog and dos
afterwards you know what I mean like
that's that's what's [__] up is that
it's like I I don't know if you feel
this way about your addictions but it's
like yeah I'm addicted to this cuz it's
[__] awesome it's [__] it [__]
rules like this is I know it's I know
tomorrow I will feel horrendous but
right now I I will never feel better
like there like I promise you my brain
lights up in a way that like when
somebody holds their newborn for the
first time I'm I'm having a better time
than they are holding their newborn when
I'm just freshly sucked off with like a
chick a fried chicken thigh in my mouth
you know what I mean like I am having a
better experience than someone who and
not even just someone who ACD had a kid
someone who tried for 10 years and they
had a miracle child and it and you know
the doctor said inv vitro won't work and
then so somehow on the anniversary of
their dead mother's birthday they
conceive and then finally the baby comes
out and it's beautiful it has no health
problems whatsoever I'm having a better
time than that guy like in in in the you
know Courtyard Marriott or watching
Diners drivein and dieses with [__] on my
belly like I promise you you know that's
fantastic fantastic but do you wake up
the next morning full of shame or do you
wake up like oh damn that chicken tender
job was great I feel I really like I
don't feel a shame I just feel like you
know hung over and [__] up yeah but
the other [__] up feeling is like I
kind of like that feeling I kind of
there's something to that like it's like
I understand that this I'm paying the
piper for yesterday and it's like I
don't have [__] to do I'll lay in my
[__] bed for 4 hours you know what I
mean like it my favorite thing that
happens on the road like and I'm getting
away from it because it is bad for me I
get that like it's getting a little too
unhealthy at a certain point you just
got to quit it but like that rhythm of
like get [__] up be so have a great
time at like you know until 4:00 a.m.
and then be so feel like such [__] that
you just have to kind of lay in your bed
take a you know cold shower have a at
that point I'm having like I have to I'm
like oh [__] a show is coming coming so
you're kind of in survival mode and
that's the only time I can kind of take
care of myself when it's like life or
death so I'm like I'm actually eating
kind of healthy that day I'm working out
to kind of get the get the juices
flowing I'm taking a nap I'm like doing
everything you need to to get your I'm
drinking green juices and [__] and then
I have like a a coffee right before the
show and then you finally feel good like
you feel like [__] all day and then you
feel good at like 700 p.m. shows at 8:
then you do the show you know how the
[__] the high after a show so now I'm
finally well rested and then it's like
what I'm going to go to bed after that
and then it's this [__] up cycle where
it's like well I'm getting [__] up now
like I'm [__] I feel great I feel
awesome I've done all this healthy [__]
today to survive but now you add you add
the like momentum of the show and you're
like yeah I'm gonna go just have a good
ass time I'm not going back to [__]
I'm not going do I'm not going to do
like yoga and go to bed I'm gonna I'm G
to have a good time what does uh
partying after a show look like at this
point it really just at this point I
mean it used to just look like you know
going out for you know hanging around
like very early on in my career it's
like when I'm I'm not doing well like
overall where it's like you know you're
just kind of in that moment you're like
in that room you're famous and nowhere
else are you famous so it used to look
like hey want to get drinks at the bar
in the comedy club where I still have
like my halo around me cuz the second
you walk out as like a young comic
second you leave the premises you're
just some [__] guy you know what I
mean you're just some guy with five
roommates after that point everybody
wants to feel important and I feel like
an absolute King when I sit on my throne
and take a huge sloppy dump with my
hello tushy bedet this is officially my
favorite sponsor of the Wild Ride
podcast I've said that the entire time I
love it so much it's like pressure
cleaning your butthole after you take a
dump and if it's a dump that follows
sto's butthole Destroyer then it
couldn't be more important to have hello
tushy it's so soothing and it's so
complete in the way that you clean your
butthole it's time to stop wiping people
and start washing your butthole and it's
time to get 10% off for your first order
by going to hello tushy
.o again for 10% off your first order
this is my favorite sponsor of the Wild
Ride podcast and it is the only way to
take a dump absolute refreshment and
total cleanliness with
hellotushy.com
steo so jump on it and let's get back to
it uh so I would just like hang out and
like get [__] up and hopefully some
woman who was at the show you know would
come back to the hotel that was probably
around the corner from the shitty comedy
club I was at uh but and then and now
it's kind of gone the full fully the
other way where it's like I travel with
my friends so that you know I have my my
best friend eldis is my road manager
he's my podcast producer too and I bring
you know a friend on the road I bring JP
McDade great you travel on a bus now not
yet we're not in the bus Zone yet but uh
we'll do like you know I'm I'm in the
SUV you know what I mean like I'm in
Sprinter van but it's like it now it
just looks like let's get high with our
let me get high with my boys and like
you know may you know not not eat
anything too too bad or or it's like
just you know DM somebody and like you
know or meet a girl at the show and be
like do you just want to hang out and
it's but I don't even like to go out
anymore it's just like let's literally
watch diner drive-ins and dives and you
know eat what's that huh I've never seen
that show what the you you know what it
you know what diners drives and Dives is
what channel is it on people still watch
TV dude come on guy Fier triple D
brother do you know what that is I I do
not but I get I get the sense that it's
uh I've been watching Suits on Netflix
you're suits guy
yeah yeah for sure you guys aren't part
of the guy you you don't know about the
guy fur extended Universe I'm a big guy
I'm a big guy guy do you I love his
stuff I know guy Fury has in a fantastic
restaurant in Vegas
best hamburger I've ever had in my life
damn dude that's all I know you just
know him from the from the food that's
good and the memes and the old TV show
but yeah no I like Hotel I don't know in
hotel rooms you get to watch your little
cable it makes you feel you know like
you're going back in time dude you know
what crazy I've been on the road with
Steve for like 10
years what how many hotels have we been
in I mean do the math right
yeah I've never turned my TV on in the
hotel room that's insane really I don't
turn wow I think that's a pleasure of a
of the road is like getting to
experience it's like you're almost in
like a time machine I feel like I want
to push back on
that we would watch an iPad but I've
never turned on a TV what what what am I
going to watch TBS with
commercials F chance in hell sometimes
they got HBO but then it's like I'd
rather just go on the HBO app I don't
know be like yeah this is what I want to
watch not what they want to give me
sometimes it's about going back to the
old ways the old the the ways of our our
forefathers you know what I mean just
throwing on the cable watching a
commercial now now stabos is over here
saying like that how great he feels when
you know when he's found a a sexual
partner no no she's not in cell anymore
I'm not in Cel but then there's Scott
over
here who's very very mums of the word
about it
you won't let us know who when you [__]
you let your boys know when you bust
that's one that's another great because
I used to be that guy where tell
everybody and then I and then I just
it's
like then I when I started getting into
therapy it was like why do you have to
tell people that right right right right
W my my take on it yes yes free my my
take on it see when when Scott and I
started working together 10 years ago I
had just gotten out of sex addict rehab
and I was like man now got to go back on
the road like dude I'm a dead duck man I
need I need someone to come on the road
and and be a professional well
be professional [__] blocker so I was
like you know just help me like not act
out with chicks yeah and uh sell merch
and stuff so Scott became like a wizard
at selling my merch we would share hotel
rooms together we both identified as sex
addicts wow interesting we were both
highly committed to our recovery yeah
and um there's something about uh sex
addiction and acting out where like
there there's a shift you know you go
from being the guy who wants all of his
Bros to know that he hooked up last
night then then you shift into like o
like like uh I'm ashamed of this it's
like Al the alcoholic sneaking drinks
yes that's a great Point sneaking [__]
keeping a little flask of [__] juice
taking a nip
and I I I can't I can't say with
certainty but I've been getting the vibe
that Scott's always like kind of going
on a date not making a big deal out of
it I feel because that makes sense
because one I used to be that guy yes
two I I like hold my job at like I don't
want to be the guy who's [__] on the
job of course so like when I'm on the
road I'm
working so he's the guy who's who's
totally acting out sexually on the job
but just trying to keep a l
on I do it I do it very rarely like but
I you know when we were in Atlanta I was
like oh I got this girl at the hotel
like there's no secrets once my work is
done right but like and there's also the
factor of like I don't it's like I don't
want to be that guy like oh I [__]
last night it's like BR you're 40 who
gives a [__] that's the thing it's so
you are the guy who [__] last night
and like like last night I know I didn't
I got in okay no I
got I got in and I I went to bed at uh
like 1:30 in the morning why was it so
important to stay in Manhattan as
opposed to just buy the podcast Studio
because we were talking about it before
there's no there's like no hotels around
here and the and the ones that were
around here were like 450 a night so I
chose the one in South in the financial
district because it's right across the
bridge and it was like okay a nice hotel
for reasonable right okay now again I I
don't I don't know anything I the only
thing I know is that is just how it
works like like once you open up the the
door like the whole gorilla comes out
you know I know is that what you call
your penis the
gorilla SC all the way to the top I'm
trying to think of even with the last
like honestly like in the last 10 years
on the road I probably hooked up with
like 10 chicks okay Scott's got like
mental contortionism to Define being on
the
road Scot like no I'm trying to think
because it's like I'm working and Scott
Ted's like I was only ever actually
laying down in the
road when I say the
road I was staying at a hotel where the
address was actually Road not Boulevard
you're you're getting [__] on an
on-ramp
yeah those are the 10 you
count only 10 times only 10
times no I I I don't I don't hook up
with chicks on the road really
like because I was like I was hired as a
[__] block and so like the first like
four or five years it was nothing
okay yeah just that's feel so you waited
the first four year four or five years
to hook up with anybody on the road yeah
because Steve I'm going to push back
up you know you know when the first time
the first time I did I remember I was uh
okay we start TR Cleveland Cleveland OH
some of the best the finest women of all
time in Cleveland maybe it was like
three three or four years in but I
remember I didn't even jack off on the
road while oh now you're getting crazy I
swear to God now it's getting now I
wasn't even there but I have to object
that's one of the most ludicrous things
I've ever heard in my life you didn't
jack off there's nothing to do butt jack
off on the road I know we were like in
an intense like sexual therapy and so
for like the first like two years three
years I didn't even jack off while we
were working wow I'd wait till we got
home
okay you're safe space we we started
traveling together in January of 2014
yeah it wasn't four or five years I mean
you and I were both said screw it like
in 2016 oh hell yeah that was when we
were in the uh what's what's that
district oh that ain't good no matter
what you know by the distri Europe
didn't count Europe didn't
count [__] were an oh that was
like two years that was
2016 we had uh our show in Ireland was
like November 30th 2016 and then the
rest of Europe and the UK was December
2016 well you guys had to lay off little
Trump had been elected you know you were
worried you're like we got to start
busting nuts he got elected had gotten
sworn that was in Europe so we called it
the end of the world
tour yeah yeah Europe was bad okay
that's awesome I love the idea that it's
like for two years you're like strictly
we're not hooking up on the road and
then you're like 2016 we did a Amsterdam
Thailand back to
Amsterdam over to over to Henderson
Nevada buny Ranch those are our three
stops
2016 yeah and and it was uh yeah 2016 it
was just kind of like a screw it and
then it I guess it was I would compare
it to like an alcoholic who's been sober
and then relapses and the relapse is
just so terrible after that they're
sober like properly that's good
sometimes you need one of those yeah
they well for me I'm like a sexual
anorexic so like I'll I'll I'll splurge
and then I'll pull back for like six
months okay Bic yeah B A Binger a binge
binge [__] eater I'm a binge I'm a so
what are you going to pull
back I'm just going to come out and say
it I don't think Scott's ever going to
pull back and I think it might have
something to do with him discovering the
powers of bluechew I think that he's
just having so much fun with the ladies
that he cannot stop and I don't blame
him because bluechew really is a lot of
fun and if you want to try it then I
think that's a pretty good idea because
it's got the same active ingredient as
both Viagra and Calis except it's
chewable and it only cost a fraction of
the price so yeah it's a good time and
you can get an entire month's supply of
blue Blu tablets absolutely for free and
only pay five bucks for shipping if you
go to bluechew.com and use the promo
code steo couldn't be more simple you
get your prescription taken care of
right there on the site super fast with
the medical provider online and then
boom an entire month supply of blue Cho
tablets is on its way to you absolutely
for free you only pay five bucks for
shipping I mean you got nothing to lose
and if you look at Scott Randolph then I
think you can tell it's going to be a
good time so go to blu.com use the promo
code steo and let's get back to it no I
mean I've been trying to like go on
dates and like dating healthly but
trying H she doing pretty
good like okay so now is she so tough
dating in La though we like like how
many
uh you know how many times have I [__]
TR of intercourse have you
had I don't even know I'm I'm G to guess
you're doing pretty strong numbers is
the scense that I get no I mean I I you
did not have any eye contact when you
said that I no no I'll be honest with
you guys I'm trying to think of like
yeah maybe the last time I [__] was
Australia but maybe not after that
probably I can't remember I think I just
like disassociate or I don't the I don't
recall defense
I couldn't tell you officer your honor I
don't remember it's all good no I plead
the fifth yeah you're pleading the fifth
you're not under oath dude this is the
in podcasting there is no constitutional
protections you're just going to get
grilled by your boys until you tell us I
honestly don't remember but if you like
brought it up i' be like oh yeah I mean
I got my dick sucked a couple weeks ago
oh so we need to remember so basically
what you're saying is Steve needs a log
of every time you [__] he needs to put
it like like a baby like a like a nurse
nursery camera in your room like to
watch babies to make sure they're not
choking in the middle of the night yeah
baby dick
monitor not to disparage you I don't
know how big your P I understand Scott
has a Warhammer oh that he's got like a
real I'm a grower not a shower nice dude
but it's bit but it grows to a nice he's
he's got a huge I I mean I guess I don't
know I don't I I've been told this is so
funny because it's like we're bullying
him for having a big dick and getting
[__] this
is this the opposite of like Middle
School like when you get sober it's like
oh what are you still getting [__] and
drinking and doing drugs you [__]
idiot like everything is flipped on his
head when like we're so washed that
we're like dude stop dude stop having a
big ass dick and having an awesome time
and getting
[__]
that's what being 40s like we have hot
sauce on
Amazon I can't believe
guy how dare
you yeah man oh dear Dam the twin sex
that's interesting you're both going
through like what is that even what's
like sex addiction rehab even like I
don't even like they're just telling you
to stop it's a sex program and I think
the definition is to abstain from
compuls
sexual behavior that causes shame oh
okay interesting so it's different for
everybody okay that makes sense the
shame part makes sense I guess yeah yeah
yeah but if you're Shameless I guess
it's the you know there's no but there
because it feels like a tough one to get
a handle on because it's like it's not
like like that's the problem with food
too is that like you kind of have to
have food whereas like with sex
addiction it's the same thing where it's
like it is I mean I guess you could
abstain for times but it's like to be a
regular well-rounded human being you
can't just cut it out right the way you
cut out AB drugs or booze or whatever so
I could see that being really hard
especially like when you finally do find
someone that you like and then you just
feel all that and then you let the genie
out of the bottle a little bit and
you're like oh this is cool I should go
pay for [__] now you know what I mean
like I should go I should get two women
to [__] me at once that's exactly you
couldn't have nailed it more that's
exactly right yeah um wa so you clearly
don't have a girlfriend or anything I
don't know yeah I uh uh I've just been
it's kind of this thing where it's like
you're where you travel all the time I
mean I don't I've been like I said I've
been on the road a long like for two
basically two plus years and uh I was
like getting out of a I was like getting
out of a relationship going into the
pandemic so like we had just broken up
and um and then you know pandemic's
[__] weird and everyone's kind of so
there was no one around then and then I
actually really liked I really like that
once the pandemic opened up and it was
like this weird you know once people
were like started going outside no one
was leaving their house like if you like
I would match with girls on Tinder and
no one was leaving their house not to
[__] in 2020 you know it was like if
we're leaving we're [__] so I kind of
liked that was actually my favorite
dating ever because it was like they'd
come over I'd Grill up a nice meal we'd
watch a movie it was really N I actually
really like that and then since then
it's just been kind of like um just I've
been just traveling way too much you
know to the point where it feels a
little like I'm not I don't think I have
like you know sex addiction but it it
starting to get to the point where it's
like not just in Sex and relationships
but like in every part of my life where
I'm like I don't even feel like I live
anywhere or that I have like these like
connections with anyone because it's
like I don't I'm just gone all the time
and I'm always in these like so all my
relationships are like you know there's
a couple you know maybe there's a couple
people that I have one cool thing is
dating girls in open relationships
because you get to like you get to keep
you don't feel guilty about not dating
them you know what I mean like seeing
them multiple times and not dating them
like you know if you see someone over
the course of years on the road I don't
know if you've had where it's like yeah
yeah it's non-committal totally it's
like you get kind of The Best of Both
Worlds in this part where it's like they
know what's up they don't care if you
[__] somebody else or whatever and it's
like you don't feel guilty because you
know they have someone they actually
love in their life and it's like you
could just be like a fun a fun time but
yeah are you seen a
therapist I was I was in therapy and
then I just literally stopped L like a
like six months ago I got really busy
and I forgot to text my therapist back
and I just straight up have not texted
him since then yeah cuz you're saying a
lot of things that I was on like on the
road and I was like talking to my
therapist like yeah I feel like this I
don't know what I'm like I don't have a
home I don't have this and and they're
like well you have to put down roots and
so that I the big step for me was I just
bought a house nice dude and part of
doing that was because there's a Sex
Dungeon in the basement by the way yeah
did you ever end up christening the
house oh we lost ey
cont yeah yeah yeah yeah sorry sorry you
were trying to con a yes I have I'm just
trying to think because
like sorry I'm a piece of [__] you
didn't deserve that no no I mean I'm
trying to think because like my memory
isn't so well because it's like what we
what we pack what we pack into a day is
like so much that I I don't remember
these excuses are getting wild what are
you guys laughing at these excuses are
crazy what are you talking about like
you're like we do so many activities I
can't remember if I had sex that's what
you're
saying yeah I mean it's like
right yeah what what are you guys
saying Help Me Help Me Maybe I'm maybe
I'm like deflecting I don't even know
what you guys are talking about it's
getting hot here you a water God damn
it no wait Vinnie explain what's going
on it just sounds like you're deflecting
a little I mean what am I deflecting
like it just sounds I have christened my
place yeah I mean it just sounds like
you're going ape [__] that that you're
active in sexual addiction is is the
kind of the do you have a girlfriend no
no okay well if you're putting down
Roots maybe that's the cuz one thought I
have had is like I'm with you where I
feel the the need to kind of like next
year I am taking a a really long break
off the road like I have this special
coming out next year but that's the
problem is like that's the problem with
this right where it's like I have the
special coming out later I can't you
know I can't say too much about it soon
but it's coming out sometime later this
year and then so I'm going to tour off
that you can't really put a special out
and then not tour off it a little bit
it's kind of a mistake I think like
you're going to have all this press from
it so like I'm going to be gone the
first few couple you know the first
quarter of next year but then after that
I'm like all right let's chill out yeah
but what if more opportunities pop up
and like I I've I've already told I was
like I'm not doing them because I just
that's what I keep doing it's like I've
said this multiple times where I'm like
I'm gonna take three months off and then
something cool happened right like I got
to do a movie uh this summer I got Bert
asked me to be a part of that awesome
tour fully loaded tour so this stuff
kept popping up but I've just I've told
my you know I told my agents I was like
I'm just straight up not doing like yeah
[__] Martin score sey is like hey you
want to make your de acting debut you
know your major Motion Picture debut
I'll be like yes I will but it's like
other than something crazy I've just
been like and don't get me wrong I'm
still going to work like I have my
podcast I'll do I'll do shows in the
city but it's that thing of like I got
to stay home and then I also want to be
like a regular human being where it's
like yeah I should probably be in a
relationship and stop like this weird
stuff where you're just kind of flirting
with like because it's definitely intg
ining they call it intriguing yeah what
emotional Liaisons when you have several
people that you're texting
nonstop now his memory Works real
good now his vocabulary snaap
back yeah
wow very clear that was real
quick good point yeah probably blocking
out probably so tour you're doing
Baltimore yeah yeah I'm on it doing four
shows in Baltimore my fall tour my fall
tour kicks off yeah I guess I'll plug
that to give you a little little
breather give you a
sec uh yeah so I'm doing the last leg of
the fat Rascal tour uh and that's this
will be the last time I do this material
um the special will come out sometime
after this so I'm in cincin the kicks
off in Cincinnati Columbus Cleveland uh
that's the first weekend in October and
then I'm doing big homecoming shows in
Baltimore six shows at the L uh tickets
still available for two of those and
then yeah then after that's like Detroit
Grand rapin Philly uh Orlando Tampa Fort
Lauderdale Milwaukee Kansas City St
Louis and then we end it at the Beacon
Theater in New York um which I'm super
[__] pumped about um which it is so
crazy like I can't believe some of the
venue like The Beacon Theater is so
beautiful and it's like you know I'm
just telling stories about like watching
myself [__] in the mirror and how
atrocious it is you know what I mean
it's like you know like Bob Dylan was in
there you know what I mean like G like a
like you it's so funny I've had very
similar situations what's the biggest uh
ven uh venue you've done
um I don't I think I did like a on this
tour we have some 3,000 seedar um but I
like a I and I mean I'm trying to get
into like the the 2500 seat thing I
really like a 1500 seat venue I think
that's kind of like it feels like a club
uh but it's big like it's kind of it's
kind of but some of these like some of
these bigger ones look so beautiful so
I'm really I'm excited to to try them
out I mean I'm trying to do less part of
the like not going crazy on the road is
also instead of doing smaller venues and
doing eight shows it's like hopefully we
can sell out one just big 3,000 Ceder
and I don't have to be gone for 6 days
or whatever it's not checking out that
um that you've yet to travel on a tour
bus yeah yeah I it's this has all
happened like this year dude like it's
been really crazy where I mean last year
I was in comedy clubs and I'll still
play comedy clubs because I like them I
mean I love standup comedy like that's
I've been doing since I was 19 it's the
only thing I've ever wanted to do
podcasting and even like having an
online presence was never something that
I like and yeah I wanted to act a little
bit but it was never something like my
passion has always been standup but yeah
in the last year it went from like we'll
play some bigger like you know the big
improvs like the 500 seed improvs and
[__] it went to that to like okay why
don't we mix in a couple theaters and
then all the tickets went up so like I
still it is hard to wrap my mind around
it like I can't I go to some of these
places and I'm like what the [__] is
going on and I don't know if you feel
this but like now there's like the
pressure of being great every time or
giving them a great show when I'm in
comedy when I was in com CL I was like
maybe three of these shows will be good
you know what I mean it's like it's like
you're not getting a good show on
Thursday I'll tell you that much that's
the warm-up day you know but it's like
but now it's like these [__]
got a babysitter they paid you know the
whole night might cost some some people
[__] got a hotel and flew in and [__]
so it's like you feel that pressure but
maybe we'll be maybe it'll be a tour bus
soon um it would also help with just
like yeah just like being healthier but
you're driving to Columbus from here in
Cleveland or no I'll fly into Cincinnati
and then we'll do the Sprinter van thing
Cincinnati Columbus Cleveland and then
we'll we'll fly back out and then
Baltimore you know I'm from there I have
a house there so that'll be easy and
then so so a lot of this tour I wanted
it to be a little a little easier on me
so it's just like weekends and it's
bigger venues but I think maybe next
year we'll try the because my my buddy
samel who just did the Pod um uh he's
he's he started doing tour buses for
longer stretches and he he was saying
how great it is when you just have it's
that great
I love it so much is our bus here today
no no where where is the bus parked do
we
know nice maybe steeve might just stay
there instead of the hotel you love it I
love it that's awesome yeah I lose my
mind over it you got the little back you
got the little back bedroom yeah hell
little back bedom make these peons sleep
in the
bunks Jeff in there beating
off you said you've got um a a house in
Baltimore how many different places do
you have homes so basically just New
York in Baltimore and um I mean I love I
don't really want to leave New York I
love it um but I just have so much F
like all my family's in Baltimore and
you know it's it's this weird thing
where also going back home kind of makes
you
remember how real [__] people live
because it's you know I'm here and I'm
35 and like to this day if one of my
friends like gets pregnant or something
I'm like what the hell are you going to
keep the kid and it's like yeah I'm 30
you know what I mean it's like in in
entertainment and [__] you could just
get so warped with like and then I go
back home and I'm like yeah my young my
little brothers who are by the way
they're 30 you know they're 32y old men
but to me they're my little brothers
it's like yeah they're married they have
like jobs they have like you know
everyone you grew up with is doing this
thing so it kind of grounds you and I
like being home and I like you know
seeing my parents and just kind of stick
with them so I I you know I'll try and
get back to Baltimore at least like two
to three months a year you know spend
and then and then New York just CU I'm
here I just love it here but I've spent
so little time this these last couple
years like I haven't been in my house
like I actually don't really feel like I
have even a place here because I've
turned my apartment into like the
podcast Studio basically nice yeah so we
have the back the master bedroom is a
podcast studio and I have a little
bedroom and then it's like people are
coming in and out all the time and you
know a two-bedroom apartment in New York
is it's nice no it's a three-bedroom
Queen so it's like it's [__] big but
um but it's like yeah it feels like your
office like it's like living in the tour
bus you know what I mean like which can
be fun but it can also be a little
little grading but you know here's a
random question yeah are you on Cameo
I'm not on Cameo have you thought about
getting on Cameo I've thought about it a
little bit Yeah CU we uh have been
working on this video just trying to
prank people on a cameo
what's the idea don't say
it I'll be a part of the prank if you
want I mean like yeah I'd love to come
up with uh some what made me think about
it was when you said uh you know your
friends get pregnant and you're like oh
are you gonna have the kid because the
don't say
it one one of the first ones that we did
we we tried to send to to David
arette yeah um we we wrote I wrote a
message oh you pretend to be a fan
asking for a camera oh hell yeah so you
ask for out of pocket [__] right I said
I wrote to David like uh saying my name
was Brad or something you know like like
hey sadly I got my girlfriend pregnant
and she wants to keep the baby you know
like can you hurt
her that's [__] awesome yeah and he
wrote back this super thoughtful like
hey you know I I believe it's the
women's choice and then like kind of
started chewing me out you know like I'm
not going to do that like and I wish you
the best but like man I really want you
to really holy [__] really awesome life
advice from David AR it was like I mean
dude he and like I know him to be that
you know I know him to be that like that
that great of a guy yeah yeah yeah what
were some of the other ones we uh asked
Lindsay Lohan to put on a British accent
and say for my British fans Elton John
is a talentless Diva and wanted to do do
different accents for my Irish fans
Conor McGregor's a [__] boy put that
and then then cap it off with and for my
Chinese oh
no and for my Islam my Muslim fans the
prophet and then it just cuts off juston
even yeah oh my God God that's those are
good bits yeah so so uh we need to have
a creative meeting today to come up with
more oh yeah oh if I think of any I'll
definitely yeah who's good some
good yeah what was
uh yeah I mean d we just we have a lot
of we laugh really
hard that that's a great use of Cameo
for sure yeah yeah I'm not I'm not going
to take it any further than that I'm
looking at the screen and it's getting
close
yeah we could probably wrap up this
video in the next couple days you think
I would love to I I I I I would love to
but the thing is that some of the stuff
we did on this Cameo video is like
pretty
radioactive like uh I've got I've got
I've got some legitimate concerns about
whether it's a good idea
to that's awesome that's great dude
that's that that's when you know you got
something good you know when you're like
oh no right oh no GNA be a huge
problem I love that the people will just
read whatever and not realize uh oh
video has been
removed well we let's talk about this
after sounds like you guys lost some
heat uh oh was that the one for the fire
department yeah it's been
removed we better have saved it I know
uhoh I mean we wouldn't have been able
to show that
anyway but yeah I mean homeboy had his
fire hose out my
God yeah we we said uh we said we said
uh this this one we said we you know I
work for the fire department and uh it
it would just mean a lot it would be a
big morale boost for the guys in the in
the department if uh you
know if you could light a candle and and
uh you know whack it with your wiener to
put it
out who would who wouldn't assume that
that's a gay man with a very specific
fetish you know what I mean like who
would take that in good
faith well we'll tell you somebody yeah
we got
somebody we know just the right
one we asked Joey Fon of v s to put on
black face to put on black face and say
black lives matter
yeah we've got we've got just the guy
that's [__]
awesome a man so uh yeah so what else
dude I mean dude not much just uh you
know I'm just out here I'm on the road I
got the the special coming up and I'm
trying to you know where's the special
coming up uh I we don't know yet or I
can't announce yet but so you know
somewhere pretty cool uh and it'll come
out we don't know the exact but later
this year so I'm really pumped about
that and then you know not much I got I
well I did a I did like a little movie
with uh a little Indie movie which is
really cool I'm editing that with some
friends right now so I'm trying to you
know trying to do some [__] like that
but you know wait when you when you're
when you're uh making all these Tik toks
these short videos do you have like
people you hire to do that for you yeah
I basically hired my best friends like I
hired uh like my friend Elders who had
no idea how to do anything like he had
no technical Acumen at all he just he
became like my right-hand man and he
started posting all that [__] and then
now it's like you know you just hire
some editor like I I have some editors
that I work with and yeah you just you
just got to have it it's like a little
machine that you got to keep going
constantly um but you know it's all good
I look at that stuff as like
advertisements for sure for my show it's
not I don't see that as like what I do I
just think I'm lucky that I can do do
crowd work in a way like if you come to
a show people some people expect it to
be all crowd work but it's like 10
minutes of crowd work where I'm just
like cuz that's always a fun part of
Comedy where you do that's another cool
thing about stand up is you get to
connect with the crowds like live
performance you get to you're right
there in front of them right and that's
awesome so it's like yeah take advantage
of that and make something that you
can't recreate anywhere else with this
specific you know uh crew uh this crew
of people um but then so it's like I
just see that as like a way to get
people into shows and then you know come
see me and we'll do you know it'll be a
completely different thing we'll talk
about a bunch of [__] so but yeah I mean
it's it's uh
it's just what you have to basically do
now it feels like you know just another
part of it but it's cool H have you ever
stormed out of an interview I've never
stormed out no no no I like to I pride
myself on being a pretty easygoing guy
you know having a good time no matter
what the situation is never stormed out
of you ever walked
out I've yeah I've
briskly no I don't do any like real
interview that's the other thing it's
like I just like you know podcasting and
just like [__] around with people and
actually having a conversation and you
know I don't do too many I haven't done
any combative interviews so who knows
right I don't even know what the gotcha
questions would really be you know right
you going with this have you had any I
know I I don't know what made
me I thought you had like a story or
something what about you have you ever
had like I'm have people ever been like
[__] to you it takes a lot to
offend me you got to you got to try
pretty hard to offend me like uh yeah
one one time uh I I got up and walked
out of an interview it was just somebody
had insulted uh the honor of somebody
else yeah yeah yeah yeah you're just
taking a stand I mean I I get that right
it's like but I I could feel I could
imagine like if anything maybe like some
interviewers would be like condescending
to you or some [__] [__] like that like
I could see that which is [__] cuz
it's like I mean I I hate that I mean I
I mean I've been a fan forever truly
like obviously jackass wild wild boys is
my [__] too you know what I mean like
and and I just think that I mean it's so
just what you do is [__] awesome and
it's so like it's the fact that
interviewers or anybody would be like
condescending about it it's just like
it's it's actually I think it's more I
think it's like uh more like like
visceral art and Noble than like a lot
of stuff that's like a lot of the middle
ground [__] that's like like really you
know maybe there's like some very high
level of works of art that we're talking
about like film stuff like that that
like most people can't touch right but
then there's like all this [__] that
people turn out that has no like human
Spirit or connection and like all the
stuff that not only is that like you
will put your body on the line to truly
like make something and entertain people
and also but it's also like that that
underlying like level of camaraderie
that all everything that I think you do
is so sick and that has that like human
feeling I mean from the first Jackass to
I mean jackass forever was like more
emotional for me than like you know a
good than like than like some [__]
highly produced Hollywood drama which
it's like cuz you actually are like
seeing these uh you know relationships
form you know in real time and [__] so n
anybody who's being a [__] to my boy
steo they need to come see me that's
what I say we [__] him up we'll send out
eldis my Albanian Video Editor to to
deal with them he's 66 and a very soft
man but maybe he looks
intimidating you know yeah good man I I
appreciate that dude I think we have a
heart out right now all right
good I think uh cool we can wrap it up
so I think think we're in good shape
anyway man I knew I was going to love
talking to you dude this is so fun thank
you and uh anytime you're back in New
York and want to come hop on St Ro come
do my part definitely love to have you
for sure yeah man um yeah yeah [__] dude
like anytime you want I would love to me
yeah and and if you're you're in LA
right you're most time I am in La so if
I'm in La I'll hit you up dude but yeah
please come on the show great meeting
you guys nice me please get your sex
addiction under
control we're all worried about you
um yeah see you guys next time yeah that
was a lot of
fun how about that my new bro stavos you
know um there's a lot going on I just
got back from the radical
Ranch been talking about this forever
Lux and I did it the place is insane
like I can't stand how much I love it
and what what else dude I might I might
as well just go ahead and tell you this
I got a release date for The Bucket List
special November
14th it's exciting and uh yeah man just
love you guys I love you guys a lot
thank you for sticking
around
yeah